I think that truth is instilled by God
in all of us and I think if you tell the
truth you're a good person so who do you
think is the bad guy you know everyone
uses they them them they're after me
who's they who's the bad guy instead of
saying who I will say what I will start
by saying is what they do and what they
do is they control information and we
now live in an Information Society and
by controlling information they control
how people think and act and react to
things that's all they have to do they
have to control information and they
have to be very selective with what they
allow you to talk about what they allow
you to discuss and what they don't and
once they can do that they can keep you
bickering about garbage and they can
control the sensitive information and
then they run the world that's how they
can purport absolute fallacies